you seen the idol I have not I've heard
about it best show on television best
show on television guys I know
everyone's still like kind of coming
down from succession succession is Young
Sheldon to the idols Big Bang Theory the
character the weekend plays who is
called the weekend as far as I'm
concerned is the most charismatic
sexiest the haircut is on point and if
you want to know what I'm like when I
flirt with people that's what I'm like
I'm like weekend finally getting to see
myself on television it feels like a win
for diversity everything the weekend
says you're like yes yes I wish I could
vote for him for president I don't call
it the idol I call it the weekend show
he said he was almost like messed up a
little coming out of shooting because he
was so deep into this character what's
been great is watching him do press and
being like guys the thing that makes the
show so great is this character is the
opposite of me like no it's not weekend
that's you you're not even trying to act
don't let people tell you it's a bad
show watch weekend show